we've secured our dependency chain we've
made sure our code is secure add a cat -
that must be secure at this point right
wrong it's time to look at protecting
our developers from devious phishing
attacks no matter how secure your
codebase is from the outside if someone
manages to get into one of your dad's
account with a good phishing attack then
all of those previous protections
useless a typical login flow looks
something like this you present your
login to the server then you're in but
oh no someone was actually giving you a
very clever phishing page and you've
given them your credentials now they can
do anything you could have done like
modify source code install malware or
even send emails of too many emojis to
your whole team what about a one-time
password generated by your phone
unfortunately that doesn't always
prevent phishing because official can
just take that pass it forward with your
connections and now they're logging in
is you just as successfully there's got
to be a better way to secure the people
who access your system and that that's
where security Keys come in they can be
used as B keys or Bluetooth or you can
even use your Android phone as one and
these serve is a much stronger second
factor to make your login secure so
let's see how security keys would have
stopped that previous phishing attempt
in its tracks instead of being complete
after you've given a login name and a
password the server replies with a
challenge because it knows that you
registered a security key on your
account already your security key
accepts that challenge verifies that it
does recognize the domain name and uses
its hidden private key to sign it this
means a phishing domain even a very
cleverly disguise them with a URL that
looks almost exactly the same except for
that weird ASCII characters using that's
not really a no but it looks like you
know yeah that won't work the key won't
sign the challenge and return it to the
domain if it isn't exactly what it was
set up with if everything does check out
your security key accepts the challenge
verifies that it recognizes the domain
name and uses its hidden private key to
sign it finally the server uses the
public key to verify the signature and
it knows you have the same physical key
that you had before now this is strong
authentication that's a very resistant
to phishing prophetic vision is just as
easy as that
once you set these keys up and change
the two-step authentication to only use
security keys and the Google admin UI
then the next time a developer logs on
after they enter their password they'll
be asked to touch their security key
plug that in give it a tap now you're in
that's the end of this little security
journey
thank you for going along this ride with
me I'm Carter Morgan and you you are now
a certified expert in all things I've
secured it or maybe not what do you
think leave your response in the
comments below and don't forget if you
want to see more great Google cloud
content like this please like and
subscribe to the page
[Music]